il est tellement fier de son
amphithéâtre à québec qu'il est en
tournée dans plusieurs villes du québec
pour le vendre dire aux gens d'aller à
québec le voir aller acheter des billets
de spectacles etc
le maire de québec régis labeaume donc
de passage dans nos studios et quelques
minutes sur la bombe au soir soit petite
visite éclair à maurienne
les éclairs même pas le temps d'aller
voir votre ami denis coderre écoutons
soit là tous les jours où se mêlent tous
les loyers pas de soucis vous venez un
vent de l'amphithéâtre or dont les gens
achètent beaucoup de bien pour aller le
visiter sa masse est gratuit non c'est
ça mais vendrely venez vous fait une
tournée pour vendre l'idée de
l'amphithéâtre et l'avenir de la découpe
de découvrir la vidéo de la visite est
bon d'y prendre goût évidemment non et
comment nous pouvons la vente de billets
justement côté dans un spectacle qui
sont prévues à l'enfant andré demande de
quebecor je m'occupe en hausse le mois
c'est le note pas si nous aurons fini le
8 et ensuite on laisse quebecor aller
jusqu'à date c'est nous qui en sommes
les propriétaires et 15 mai les gérants
encore alors c'est notre vertueuse
l'ouverture de la ville de québec
quebecor se cherche des partenaires pour
la nouvelle équipe de hockey
pourquoi pas la ville de québec ils vous
prennent partenaires
je pense que c'est une très mauvaise
nous sommes allés au notebook effet on
and half t as qu on ne construit à 30
millions abbott des coûts prévus on est
très heureux
alors on m'a donné ce n'est plus notre
business comment ça va l'arrivée de
cette nouvelle équipe qu'est ce que vous
en savez quelle soupe nous en dira
écoutez moi je voudrais qu'on a du
succès depuis bon tout d'abord les gens
nous ont donné mandat pour bâtir un
amphithéâtre le financer on le bâti à 30
millions de moins que prévu
quebecor est maintenant gestionnaire
passait et a réussi à chaque fois alors
je présume que si on doit le succès
jusqu'à la fin devrait y avoir un
enfin russe de tout ça alors vous
comprenez ma prudence parce qu'on est
vers la fin alors ouais c'est ça mais je
ne dise plus superstitieux super cieux
mais je suis est très politique si l on
passe après très bientôt le pas pas
évidemment à l'automne mais possiblement
au projet au 10è la maladie souhaitée
troisième est en cours alors ça devrait
finir je plaisante cet automne et à
partir de là les commissaires et les
propriétaires vont voir s'ils prennent
la décision eu le vote pour une
exploration ça leur est par ces deux
jours vous avez votre avis théâtre est
ce que vous allez appuyer le maire de
montréal s'il veut des fonds publics
pour un stade de baseball à celui ci est
je pense que ce qui a été fait à québec
devrait être fait pour montréal pour un
stade de baseball avec ce une bonne idée
le retour des expos je pense que c'est
une bonne idée je pense que ça vaut la
peine qu'ils aiment reste une métropole
les grandes villes nord-américaines ont
tous un club de vêtements moi je pense
que ça aurait jamais dû quitter mais pas
encore la guerre des chouans fin mai ce
serait une bonne idée pour montréal
c'est le serment
un autre fait des sous à vendre une
équipe de hockey vous avez dans votre
mii remercions au but et vous lalala une
méga chicane qui est maintenant devant
les tribunaux
on va pas tout refaire l'histoire mais
ce que ça veut dire pour les québécois
que le rêve olympique notre québec les
jeux olympiques vin c'est terminé il
faut plus penser a choisi ces mois ci si
on applique pour les olympiques brèche
qui exactement comme on va le faire dans
quelle formule et c'est pas dans la
formule actuelle
maintenant je dire j'ai décidé on
apprend que gervais elle par exemple
n'ont pas du tout une façon de la faire
mais bien pour faire pousser d'agglo
c'est moi qui décide et qu'on laisse
tranquille
alors c'est toujours les maires des
villes qui décède j'ai pas besoin de
personne pour repousser l'adoption
dessinée gens qu'on y va on ira avec la
formule que je privilégie mais pour
l'instant là on va commencer par un truc
d'arc et on verra mais est-ce que vous
devriez pas pour les bonnes relations
vous réconcilier avec le président du
comité olympique canadien parce que ça
ça va passer par lui inévitablement par
une autre fusion et vous j'espère être
encore dit si jamais on demande désolé
petrochem et donc c'est pas c'est pas
mis de côté pour vous ce projet la
banque russe sa résidence
mais c'est vraiment pas une priorité
mais la façon dont je veux le faire je
pense qu'on va surprendre le cio si je
mens yvan avant de vous quitter votre
liste d'épicerie pour les politiciens
fédéraux il passe à québec les
conservateurs sont plutôt généreux avec
vous il vous aime beaucoup et bien oui
parce qu'il ya des demandes
particulières et la fusion village
théâtre on revient de vacances et on va
remettre nos devant sur la table on va
demander aux tout-petits s'engager parce
que l'enfant la campagne est très long
que je pense qu'on a encore le temps et
après vous rencontrer les chefs aussi je
connais normalement ils pensent d'abord
à québec qui viennent nous voir mais
monsieur harper toujours chez vous la
vie au québec
après une audience ou 20 d'entre nous
j'aime bien le québec merci l'émouvant
s'appréciait la prochaine